hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become do you experience tight and
sore muscles after your workout session
do you complain that I am just not
flexible the good news is you can
increase your flexibility by stretching
regularly so let's go through a really
simple yet effective ten-minute stretch
sequence which you can do first thing in
the morning and this will also boost
your energy levels so let's go through
each stretch for about one minute long
ok so we want to stretch at the entire
body start by standing right at the
corner of your mat and this stretch you
will not require a lot of space at all
so you can do this in your bedroom ok so
the first stretch is going to be
inchworm I want you to stand at the
corner just reach up stretch up look up
and reach down slowly inch forward okay
get into a plank position through your
body and inch back so slow inch good
stretch your hamstring which I began
give thanks to the beautiful day back
down and slowly inch forward keeping
your legs straight ok do not bend your
knees to your hamstring stretch press
down into the floor and back good and
now please in and go back down keeping a
lick straight and slowly inch forward
very good into a nice plank view your
shoulders press into the floor and go
back very good and now just breathe in
and relax good the second stretch will
be plank to downward dog ok so I want
you to start in a plank position
and just pull your butt up into the air
into a nice downward dog view your
calves and back down into a plank and
back up so these are all dynamic
stretches to really stretch you and tie
your body out and also at the same time
you're lengthening your muscles so good
down with duck press your heels into the
floor and release into a nice plank good
and every time you do that you will feel
that your calf muscles will loosen up
good as you press into the floor feel
your back being stretched out as well
okay press in look in between your legs
release into a plank very good if you
want to you can walk it out a little bit
to feel that stretch even more good just
walk it out and just come back up very
good
the next will be lunch with a twist okay
so stand right at the edge of the mat
step forward lunge and I want to just
step and twist to the side good now
bring it back change leg step hands down
and twist good so open up and look up
back opposite side and twist so you will
start to also warm up your leg skip step
down and
very good again lunge back step forward
and get it there you go
so use the pole from your legs to step
forward and step back and open up your
chest twist look the opposite side step
forward and open up look up good few
more and open up very good now just
relax further the wall let's stretch
your groins and until your inner thighs
okay so start back get into a nice plank
position
all right one leg right leg to your
right hand and just push it open it up
and release change left side again
dynamic stretches okay so we're not
holding the stretch we're flowing
constantly take it back right leg push
open up through your groins for your
butt cheek feel your inner thighs let's
bring it back into a plank and push it
open it up keep going
step forward
back push it open it up down bring it
back one more on the right side open it
up do you the stretch good and then
bring it back good and now get back up
and let's do subtle stretch okay so this
will really target your inner thighs and
your glutes as well so stand white face
forward and I want to just go side to
side so sight and sight good just bounce
slightly and just keep it gentle keep it
flowing you should feel your inner
thighs being stretched out keep your
chest up open up your chest and push
your butt back good keep going keep your
heels on the floor very good every time
you move I want you to go deeper go
lower and stretch even more that's how
you increase your flexibility by going
deeper every stretch good keep going
keep flowing push your butt back open up
my chest and look straight ahead
very good breathe remember to breathe
with every stretch going last one and
stand up good now let's get into a
reverse plank okay so start on your butt
place your hands on the mat okay I want
to get up into a reverse play this way
and just bring your butt down and push
it up so just stay on your heels bring
it down gentle push it back up squeeze
your butt and bring it down imagine
that's a string pulling your belly
button right up down up look up and down
nice and controlled up and down very
good
this is a reverse plank and you will
really feel it on your butt cheeks and
also your hamstrings good
every time you repeat push and go higher
nice and your upper body should just be
relaxed
down up one more hand down right cat and
cow stretch this stretch everybody knows
this and it is really good for your
lower back okay so get into all fours
right ready so arch look down curl your
body and now reverse good look up feel
your little back being stretched out and
now curl it good relax the shoulders
feel your shoulders and arch so your
feet should be flat on the floor good
curl within and without and breathe out
nice Aleksey shoulders press into the
floor arch look up reverse plus one more
are very good and now I just want you to
drop your body onto the floor and give
me a nice Cobra stretch okay so I'm
square side close to your chest and
gently roll your shoulders and push
yourself back up and feel your back
being stretched out very good and again
lower it down and press it back up good
so do not punch okay remember to push
and bring your shoulders down and let's
get back down every time you repeat go
deeper go for the challenge yourself
even more if you have tight lower back
this is a really good stretch for you
down again look down push up and feel it
even more on your lower back squeeze
your butt cheeks feel it even more good
down again one more push it up
very good and now just bring your butt
back and fall into a nice Child's Pose
your favorite course everybody loves
face okay so just relax into the pose
remember this is a relaxing position
don't try too hard to make it
complicated okay just relax
sink your butt in and just stretch it
out feel your back stretched out if you
want to you can inch forward slightly to
feel a deeper stretch okay
just relax into the pose send to your
mind focus on your breathing breathe in
and breathe out you can also bring your
hands back okay and just let your body
collapse and allow your the gravity to
stretch and your entire body out good
very good
and no slowly come back up stand back up
I want you to take few deep breaths
alright so this is my favorite I mean I
want you to release all your bad energy
okay and start your day right so breathe
in as you come down a side kick again
bounce it breathe in stretch out stretch
up ready
give me two more breathe in reach up
stretch tiptoe one last one I came one
left on guys for good luck to study a
day right with ease taking all the rest
you can take in stretch up
very well done okay so these are really
simple and gentle stretches which you
can do first thing in the morning it
will help you to increase your
flexibility over time and most
importantly you will have more energy to
start your day okay
you should feel more awake and trust me
you will have an amazing day ahead all
the best
don't forget to stretch Dave